this Sunday of course is Father's Day a
day when all the dads out there can
expect to be celebrated honored and
appreciated but you got to work for it
not a guarantee I had a very candid
conversation with some dads from all
over the country about the ways that
fatherhood has changed their lives and
what it means to be a good dad
especially a good dad right now we spoke
about protecting shaping and caring for
kids during a time with so much hurt
pain and upheaval particularly over
racial injustice you have that privilege
of becoming a father you have a higher
sense of purpose you've now entered that
selfless zone where there are
individuals that is far more important
than you are how did you define being a
good father being present more
meaningful for me I wasn't raised by my
dad in fact I've only met him three
times what it meant to be a dad was
simply to be President looking at
today's world I would say it is time
time was the most important thing in a
time I would define a great father
it's a father to the three sons what's
important to me is not for them to
emulate me or essentially grow up to be
like me but
better than me you know somebody that
gives their kids too confidence to go
tap with the world with a full head of
steam part of that means equipping their
kids with tools to overcome adversity
father I am indicating my daughter to be
a citizen of the world and to look at
things for what they bring to the table
and not based on appearances being a dad
of color comes with a level of pride
that I don't think that anybody will
understand
I want her to know how the world works
like her kids that don't look like her
he's trying to figure out the right
words to say it's not he grows up I want
him to be able to just walk into a room
and know that he supposed to be there
and why is he supposed to be there
because his dad helped prepare him to be
there as father's have an opportunity to
make the change from this generation to
the next how do you make that change as
a dad he's going to experience every
single thing that I went my only job is
is to make sure I approve any tree that
they might be in the way that I can we
can move I'm awful that my daughters are
going to be able to you know they always
have choices no matter what anyone says
to them and they never stop loving
themselves to help them understand you
know who they are and to have pride in
who they are and to where and understand
what it is to be you know young black
boys as a badge of honor
and to wear that badge on apologetically
challenged myself to take the long way
to school or to bake it now let them sit
for your lap for next even though
there's no
great picture most of the time is the
key phrase there
first of all Bravo Jana Tasha is saying
Chris gajillion and Gloria who put that
piece together I think it was a
wonderful one and Gail I know you like
to rag on my nerdy dad Footwear but my
Father's Day gift is already arrived and
it is more nerdy dad Footwear I was
gonna say Tony this is 2020 you don't
need to wear Birkenstocks and should
work and socks and socks but ok whatever
you guys like at your house but listen
lovely tribute to your mother and no a
beautiful tribute to you and Anthony on
this Father's Day weekend congrats
beautifully done man